lassen sie mich nun die leitlinien für
die umsetzung des regierungsprogramms
darstellen
zunächst zu den inhaltlichen
schwerpunkten
wir werden einen fokus auf cyber defense
legen und diesen bereich massiv personal
aufstocken
wir werden die abc abwehr stärken die
gerade jetzt in zeiten von kogit 19
stark im einsatz war
wir werden schutz und hilfe zonen in
ganz österreich errichten für den
katastrophenschutz klar definierte
autarke kasernen die direkte
ansprechpartner sein sollen
zweitens der fokus wird auf verstärkung
der truppe liegen
dazu haben wir bereits eine maßnahme
getroffen die einführung von zwei
möglichkeiten der tauglichkeit unter von
traurigkeit die bereits im nächsten jahr
auch in kraft treten wird und von der
wir uns erhoffen und erwarten dass wir
zwischen zwei und dreitausend mehr
grundwehrdiener erhalten werden
die miliz wollen wir stärken und
weiterentwickeln
sie war ja erst mal gegeben im einsatz
an erstmalige teil aufbietung wir haben
hier ganz großen nachholbedarf
nachholbedarf was die ausrüstung
anbelangt neubeschaffungen auch
notwendigkeiten regelmäßig zu üben und
daher sind wir stolz darauf dass wir für
diesen bereich ihnen mitteilen dürfen
dass wir ein zusätzliches budget
erkämpfen konnten für die miliz in der
höhe von 200 millionen euro an
zusätzlichen mitteln
wir müssen unsere organisation
verschlanken und wir müssen die gefäß
ebenen reduzieren weil der
doppelgleisigkeiten festgestellt haben
insbesondere innerhalb der verwaltung
der letzte aber ohne zweifel wichtiger
punkt wir
unsere auslandseinsätze werden diese
auch weiterhin sicherstellen
wir sind zwar ein kleines land aber wir
sind ein renommierter und international
sehr geschätzter partner bei den
verschiedensten you und uno missionen
wir werden das selbstverständlich unter
berücksichtigung der neutralität der
militärischen landesverteidigung machen
und natürlich auch im zusammenwirken mit
dem bundeskanzleramt und mit dem
außenministerium